this movie exists ah just what we need a
gritty neorealistic reboot of the King
Disney logo once upon a time in the
hidden heart of France narration also
France has a hidden heart no country is
not even the size of Texas and Texas as
hard is where the stars at night are big
and bright so that's definitely ain't
hidden oh how divine that's right kids
there's some extra singing in this book
so that we can pad the runtime and sell
more tracks on iTunes clean this is 100
games I'm starting to worry about
stanley tucci becoming typecast as that
dude that wears the wigs or that dude
will do anything for a paycheck well has
a door right behind the throne in the
throne room and why is it a lot also we
know that there's a big-ass front door
on this castle but the enchantress takes
the side door to properly buzz kill the
entire shindig repulsed by her Haggard
appearance the prince and the woman away
yeah he's a dickhead but he's also
probably pretty pissed this old lady
crashed his party demanded a room and
waved a flower in his face when he
dismissed her again the old woman's
outward appearance melted away to reveal
a beautiful enchantress entrapment also
it's already maddening that I'm watching
the exact same thing story is the
animated movie that came out 26 years
ago it's exactly the shopper shop remake
of psycho in 1998 only if a movie that
featured Vince Vaughn jerking off had
made over a billion dollars and placed a
powerful spell on the castle and all The
Enchantress gave the Prince to putting
chances in five minutes to not be an
asshole and because the asshole every
motherfucker in the vicinity was screwed
The Enchantress had erased all memory of
them from the minds of the people they
loved that's an excellent attempt achill
as a plot hole opened by the animated
movie but it leaves me with a whole new
set of questions did The Enchantress
also erase all physical evidence of
their existence including portraits
letters or things they made and I'm sure
some mothers and fathers worked in the
castle that their spouses suddenly think
storks brought them their children or
they were miraculously conceived if not
he would be doomed to remain a beast for
or at least until the next reboot sequel
which should be coming out in roughly 14
months everyday like the one before
harmonious Hermione everyone in this
town opens up their window and doors at
the exact same time even though there
are occupations like bakers and
policemen like that which should be
working at a much earlier hour Oh JA
background public intoxication
incarceration is background how do you
know something again I believe I have do
I really need to point out that everyone
in this movie that sit deep in France
has English accents except for Lefou and
Lumiere I guess so the director said
here let's have you eat an apple in the
scene we'll make it look like even more
of an S hey that's an actual ass eating
an apple holy just gonna be trolling us
this lyric made sense when adults were
singing it in the original movie but
having a bunch of kids mark shame Bell
makes me think Bill Condon promised all
his nieces and nephews they could
totally be in his movie I can't tell
who's a bigger dick in the situation the
girls for singing about how weird Bell
is right in front of her or Bell for
almost stepping all over their clean
clothes Jesus movie I know you probably
had a large floral budget but this is
all the flowers look at challah through
my future wax we interrupt this musical
number to bring you some good
old-fashioned Disney sanctions talking
ever since the war I felt like I've been
missing something you know what the
first movie was missing more unnecessary
guests on backstory even for this movie
simple
[Music]
King millenials another easy
buckwheat Ron Jesus Christ Murray's even
gets a cool song in this version that's
next an aria from that chick that's it
Bonjour a few minutes ago police not
only sketches his daughter obsessively
he also has a miniature model of himself
painting the painting that's hanging
right beside it I think I prefer the
crazy inventor that adorably everything
up Maurice from the last movie Joe
Maddon's was fearless I dan this movie
about a girl that's captured by a
magical beast takes forever to actually
beast so what can I bring you from the
market they'll spent all morning at the
market at which every conceivable item
was available edible or otherwise but
Maurice is hitting up yet another one in
order to finally kick this plot he asked
teaching another girl to read isn't one
enough
that's books just have to taste am I
looking what the punishment for teaching
a young girl to read is to empty out all
bells laundry on the street these tell
silk have gone from singing about how
curious Bell is the outright public
humiliation well I wanted to teach a
child to read beauty in the dangerous
mines on the Beast the only children you
should concern yourself whether your own
Ruby can't decide if it wants to pad its
runtime with a ton of extra songs or a
pad its runtime with a ton of village
centric tomfoolery but by god it will
tad its runtime
Boldin by the success of another emma in
a recent musical emma watson is
perfectly fine with being just ok at
singing yeah if that's the village way
back there bill just covered at least a
mile on foot within two measures of the
song if the opening credits are an
indication bill should have an excellent
view of the magical kingdom from up here
you know where we awful Eve was I doubt
for ease goes to the same market every
year you ask about every year
every year you bring it but this time
not only gets lost he seems completely
unconcerned about it
Sulli pecks not gonna also come the gone
these old we're standing there ready for
a tasty dave to fall off the clip
there's a much bigger and meteor target
that's apparently standing right in
front of them
since this movie suffers from the exact
issue about the castle being in plain
sight I'll just repeat the same sin I
gave the last movie the Beast has only
been secretly feasting for ten years but
my race is somehow unaware of this very
nearby castle also it's super weird that
the villagers wouldn't be at all
disturbed that the Prince of the very
nearby castle hasn't been seen or heard
from in years and even if this princess
a peculiar cluesive you'd think that
someone would know one of the 300
live-in servants and wonder where they
are right right also in the last movie
this event occurs almost eight minutes
earlier so you see what I mean what the
whole pad the runtime thingy okay I know
I'm being hard on this movie mostly
because it sucks and was completely
unnecessary but I will give it credit
for looking freaking beautiful set
design and the castle is unbelievable oh
thank you
I know Maurice is supposed to be kind of
an idiot and movie does half the movie
but why the hell would Maurice think
this meal is for him good night wait
roses promise Bela Rose Marie stops to
get Bela souvenir from his horrific
ordeal at the castle so they can both
look at it and cry together in terror
hey pan this works but what if she is
the one the one who break this bad
Lumiere has all three of his candles lit
when it's broad daylight but was
flameless last night when Marie's came
back maurices cough could have come from
anywhere in the castle but bill goes
directly to the tower where he's held
this is the best father-daughter
echolocation trick since taken to now go
before she finds you Oh Maurice plays
the burndown game so that we can get a
properly dramatic introduction to the
beast
punish me not him no he means forever
apparently that's what happens around
here when you pick a flower damn all the
sudden it's apparent that Maurice would
be excellent at sin offense now I won't
let you do this yeah I'll totally be
fine just got a terrible disease that
will disappear the minute I leave this
castle
me everything I am is because of you
bill rubs it in maurices face that he
single-handedly made her into a moody
wander listing social pariah alo beauty
and the beast' franchise continues its
curious tradition of giving the voice of
Lumiere to anyone but a French dude it's
man of yours it's dangerous
ignoring the fact that Belle is well
within earshot what about Linear's plan
seems dangerous trying to set the beast
up with the one woman that's come by to
the castle right before the last petal
of the flower drops sure you may be
pissed at the beginning what else is
Lumiere supposed to fucking do wait for
the next one to come by good one I feel
I need be thought this opera singer
turned wardrobe thing wasn't weird
enough so it gave her narcolepsy are all
these flying fabrics also sentient if so
why do they have less individuality than
the fucking dog footrest what are the
rules
[Applause]
Tom Josh GAD choose the route of the
scene and in this instance it is not a
good thing I eat five dozen eggs so I'm
roughly the size of a ball
this song is a great example of why a
movie is so stupid
the use of animation to make these
preposterous claims as a million times
more fun than watching Josh GAD and his
invisible wires fell she's locked in a
dungeon who's gotta even in desperate
situations Maurice simply cannot stop
playing the pronoun game Al Murray what
indication is the movie given us that
Maurice is crazy he's a widower that
makes pretty amazing trotsky's and cares
for his daughter even though the movie
is over two hours it ain't got time to
explain that he's don't all the come see
I didn't think it was possible but they
actually made the Beast less likable in
the beginning of the first movie also
I'm going to go ahead and give the BCG a
perspective soon for how cheesy and
dated it's going to look in ten years
also why did they have to CG the Beast
there are a million ways to dress Dan
Stevens up to look realistic via
costumes and practical effects but this
will fuck it was mostly done windows 98
paint program and when she opens the dog
give her a dashing debonair smile come
come show me the smile show me the girl
mirror isn't also thank God the Beast
looked in on bail when she wasn't
continuing to try and climb out the
window which for some reason she stopped
doing i gue to be more feathers and I
just like yesterday I know darling I'm
getting more metallic every day oh it's
perfectly good got a feel for the castle
staff but this was the worst day
Enchantress could do I mean I guess I
understand changing the Prince into a
beast for being a dick but why did she
turn the staff into furniture and
appliances even if you were trying to
punish them for some bizarre reason why
aren't they also animals how lovely
tonight your acquaintance Nanny McPhee
isn't Jessica Fletcher at the scene
aah gasps Bianca Jota sell this to the
test hearing an inferior version of a
classic Disney song you've heard a
million times it's like listening to
Justin Bieber try and sing like Kurt
Cobain um believe me
I the D shed so all the dishes also
servants in the house and if so would be
difficult to ask them anything because
they're almost just normal dishes
the only discernible difference these
dishes have two standard dishes is that
they can fly in coordination to a
musical number and if these dishes
actually have human souls trapped inside
of them then what happens when the spell
is broken is the entire castle suddenly
devoid a flatware and fine china on hold
yeah man damn it if only Bell spoke
French also loop this menu there a
character here that would be able to not
only will depend but perfectly print
Lumiere
cloth napkin dance is a PSA on how not
to do fire safety ah those good old days
when while you swung a Cogswell they'll
smile is saying I appreciate the effort
of the musical number but I haven't
eaten in days and would prefer to just
have a nice hot meal in peace and this
ornate fanfare is keeping me from it
literally strangely doubles down on the
psychedelic teapot scene that was so out
of place in the animated version Lenina
truly Lumiere offers a tiny amount of
food to the woman he's been openly
tempting for the entire length of a
Disney World ad holy beast feels the
need to candle got some candles just
nobody trying to tell me by showing me
this is this a bed now has he been
eating a deer right here and leaving the
antlers this is a failed arts and crafts
project man what are you doing getting
out there which is shockingly easy to do
Elle is easily disarmed by CGI fakery
seriously I guess these wolves aren't as
bad as a Scorpion King or anything but
it's clear the movie blew its effects
budget on that be our guest showpiece I
just beat so good at fighting other
beasts when The Enchantress enchanted
him it was really all just about
appearances right so it's not like he
should have Wolverine like abilities
against these wolves shot looks less
like beasts about to faint and more like
there's a glitch in the computer yes
beasts just save Belle's life and yes we
got to get this creepy love story
started but for reals why the hell would
she not run here he's literally said one
nice thing to her during her
imprisonment and that was under duress
from a servants let's say this did just
get up walk over and hop on top of a
leap how is Philippe able to walk after
his experience with the wolves plus
carrying a 400-pound beast on his back
it was downed by lightning at the time
but now it's resumed an upright position
I guess the forest also has something to
gain from the curse being broken since
it's currently in with Maurice and
making him look insane to Gaston and all
the other townspeople that way
definitely that way I'm done playing
this game
Bill's Gaston wrote all this way with
maurice but gets fed up right before the
entrance of the magical forest you'll
soon have been in a West Wing well you
should learn to control your temper fell
sick burn is much more painful with a
beast than the wolf bites when the
master lost his mother and his cruel
father
twisted him up to be just like him we
did nothing and that is why we were all
including my young son just asking to be
cursed forever also does anyone expose
out of earshot in this movie this number
is for all the people that were
clamoring for a lost childhood song to
be added to the original soundtrack from
the last back-and-forth the master
remains a beast forever
and we become antiques what kind of bold
enchanting is this bull after the flower
petals fall the Beast keeps beasting for
all time but the staff die god damn lets
us do price to pay for not intervening
and a kid's abusive upbringing
[Music]
who've you forgot about the last time a
petal fell when there was a minor
earthquake in the castle that the staff
all recognized thank thank you I guess I
guess that makes a rare appearance here
too ex machina Marisa situation that
remind us that she's a character that
will likely do the same to the whole
movie by the end of it are you making
jokes now so has Belle just put away all
thoughts of escape even though if she
was easily able to do it before even if
she wants to help and get the staff back
to normal she's still digging around in
the librarian starting up beast eale
romance instead of doing anything that
would be helpful
he was mean he would coerce non-risk
fine but that was way back yesterday so
I'm sure he's worked all who stopped
waiting small yeah who knows with this
pace bill may be pregnant by then a
little gift
The Enchantress book Trudy Nagi to
escape but I think in Contra stop by
after cursing the fuck out of these
folks and dropped off a gift some
clueless printable yeah except for
cursing the hundreds of innocent people
agile a book that allows you to go
directly to certain places is totally
different than a boot or Triwizard cup
or a statue head or anything else that
rhymes with short Pete this is the Paris
of my childhood movie throws yet another
unnecessary song at us that you probably
won't remember within five seconds of
watching this movie what's the one story
I'm talking have a bring himself to tell
I need better than talk what even know
what happened to your mother because
your dad appeared ooh joked up about it
to tell the story and for that reason
you never were compelled to ask or
demand to hear it works for the
screenplay but it makes no fucking sense
you must leave now
Disney says give kids childhoods we're
gonna go all plague on their asses I'm
sorry culture fathers see so bygones
then they'll can go back to Marines and
not be a prisoner for the rest of
eternity yes some if you try to kill
Maurice last night everyone was calling
more he's crazy but now he comes in and
impugns the most famous person in the
town and everyone believes him even a
little cheese the one main character is
the one cliche instead of a date beast
and Belle agree to get dressed up and
have a good old-fashioned staring
contest
[Music]
the animated version has much more
amazing camerawork and movie magic than
this retread but this does have 97% more
move busting like at the coat rack talk
some of the staff members were turned
into mute versions and some work so does
that mean The Enchantress went through
them one by one
oh girl time so much pause I was the one
who had it all
beast spends what he thinks are his
final moments ratcheting up yet another
forgettable addition to the soundtrack
damn they still have Maurice at the bar
he was accosted by Gaston Scoones way
back before the Beast even took a bath
then he and Belle got all dressed up
danced the discount Peabo Bryson had
their talk mirrored broke up and beast
had time to sing an unnecessary song
from the breed close-up look of Maurice
in the mirror that showed him struggling
Belle was not only able to glean his
exact location but timed her entrance to
perfectly intercept the asylum wagon the
monster has under his spell if I didn't
know better I'd say she even cared for
him this is a ridiculous assumption to
make on Gaston spark I know he's a sandy
puddle but he's still trying to get with
Belle right so why throw her under the
bus in front of a whole town everyone's
all bloodlust Dion but no one has a clue
about where the castle is even if the
mirror shows the castle itself it
doesn't show the route also is it
Maurice vindicated now no one's saying
he's under the Beast spell so why does
he have to stay locked up in the cart
there's one thing this town does
exceptionally well it's mobilized an
angry mob they got ready for this beat
on like a NASCAR pit crew as the movie
progresses the time to get between the
village and the castle is shrinking took
more than half a day for Maurice to get
out there in the first place but by this
point the villagers can make it back to
that in less than a song on foot I know
what happened to mammal even though the
castle is under attack we've still got
time for some backstory both about
Belle's mom sorry old friend it's hero
time instead of continuing to attack
Gaston the castle staff lets him whittle
equip all over the floor yeah it's
shocking how Pirates of the Caribbean
this thing ends up feeling Castle begins
crumbling like the boss level of some
Super Mario game for no other reason
besides adding suspense movie was
definitely going for the record of most
edits within a rooftop jumping sequence
but unfortunately still came up short
too Captain America Civil War Strega are
coming this gets a little presumptuous
about how this night is gonna end it was
an honor to serve with you
the owner was mine
main characters are fully objectified in
the order of their caste billing because
we need to see the first of many curtain
calls in the school movie I love you
luckily bill waited until the Agatha
chantry's was within earshot to express
her love for the Beast I mean if you're
a magical entity who's cursed set the
plot in motion then showed up right at
the last minute to right all the wrongs
and dramatic fashion that's the ultimate
acts market right yeah Gong's now hand
off that obi-wan share a brief moment
before heading off to fight Voldemort
so there now don't ever be a dick again
or I'll curse the entire country mother
fuck you yeah milk damn the prince looks
like he's totally ready to chill down at
the beach and knock back some sick cold
ones bro how would you feel about
growing a beard
oh you movie it takes almost four
minutes for a movie to complete the task
of sucking its own
[Music]
he taxed the village to fill his castle
with the most beautiful people to look
at Hollister you to what he's peeping
tom
she's the only guard this man I don't
know what I'm going back before either
of you come up with another clever idea
to get us killed or what expel give our
dashing debonair smile come come show me
this man
[Music]
you are the ones most gorgeous thing
I've ever seen who are you who you know
look at me